not yeah I mean these these are real
challenges and real hard issues for any
parent to have to go go through
um but we I'd ask ask you you know let's
say I I'm pregnant and then I have have
a child and my child's disabled you know
my child is born and I find that my
child's disabled can I kill my child
once it's born
well I mean obviously not but why not
why not if it's disabled it's not going
to have a good quality of life is it
well yeah but at that point it's already
been born I mean you're not just gonna
kill your child because once it's been
born it's disabled but
so what's the difference between that
born child and The Unborn Child well I
don't think abortion's murder so
that's my opinion on it so so yeah so
then your so your issue is not
necessarily about disability it's about
um choice
yeah so I was just saying like if they
said you know some children live until
like the one the two the three if
they're really really disabled and
they're going to be completely dependent
on the parent for the rest of the life
and the doctor saying you know they're
going to be like really disabled would
you be would you still say to like a
mother like don't
get an abortion like carry on and you
know bathe the child yeah I mean I don't
think that the disabled people are less
valuable or less Human Than able-bodied
People and whether I don't think they
should be killed born or unborn because
I think science tells us that they're
just as much human in the womb as they
are outside of the womb and I don't I
don't know if you know this but that's
like a common argument for you do you
know what Eugenics says
anyone Eugenics no okay it's basically
like trying to get like a more pure
population so a lot of people would
um like um a lot of people would do that
through like a um
through
what would they say so Planned
Parenthood in the U.S was started by a
racist and basically her whole plan was
to abort
they put abortion clinics in like the
black community there and then also in
low-income areas and then like disabled
like she felt like um you need to get
like a more pure population So when you
say like should you abort disabled kids
it's kind of an argument for eugenics
but I mean I don't think you actually
think that but that's just um
here go ahead go ahead brief out of
interest if you yourself
um experience something in life that
left you in a position where you were
unable to look after yourself and you
were unable to speak and I'm able to
communicate and able to be able-bodied
do you believe in uh I think I'm saying
this right is it euthanasia when you're
allowed to oh my God is that the correct
word see it's hard I don't like don't
think I believe in euthanasia but if I
couldn't move oh my God like what would
you do at that end so like as a
as a being that has like moved through
certain stages of like human uh
development for again once for a better
word would you yourself at the end of it
um would you still continue to desire to
be alive despite the fact that you had
no ability to continue experience in
life as you previously had like do you
believe in euthanasia at the opposite
end of life also or is it just yeah yeah
or is it just that they're uh beginning
of the human creation I personally
believe that every human being is made
in the image of God so that we all have
um we're gifted with with value and we
have purpose and that our reason for
being is outside of our ourselves our
own there's a higher purpose and so yeah
personally I'm not saying these things
are easy but yeah I would I would say
I'd have to trust God and you would like
out of no choice of your own
um continue like you wouldn't have a
choice but to be alive but if someone
close to you was in that situation and
you knew that there and they had
expressed verbally their decision or
like um their desire maybe is a better
word to want to be
um again like I'm gonna use the words
put down just because I don't know a
better phrase for it at the opposite end
of of the human creation is that
something like someone that was close to
you if they become um
severely uh disabled is it something
that you would respect as of their wish
because they was able to communicate it
and it was put on them as a Twist or is
that still regardless for you uh a
non-muver like no matter what
communication had received like even if
someone you love had had explained to
you really deeply that they didn't want
to be alive if they were within a
certain State and they chose verbally to
you confirmed that they did not want to
be alive and wanted to continue down the
euthanasian I don't know if that's the
plural for it process would is that
something that you would uh respect or
is that something that you would still
strongly disagree with just funnily
enough
um my grandmother when she was alive she
she used to express
um that she wished she could go to
Switzerland
yeah she's she said that like because
she at the end I mean she
it wasn't like a long long drawn out one
but she made comments like that but um
because then it would be her choice
right it wouldn't be well I think that's
the highest suicide I don't want to
misquote this but I'm pretty sure that's
like the highest suicide rate is among
the elderly and it's not always
um recorded because
um sometimes it's like I slipped and you
know yeah it just get classified as old
age right yeah yeah I just I just think
there's always hope whether I think
there's always hope you know there is
I'm not saying these are not easy
situations but I think that there is
pain relief there is
um when when someone is in those
difficult situations it's an opportunity
for people around them to just show love
to show compassion to care for and yeah
I just I just believe in life and I
believe in hope so even if you had a
verbal confirmation of tourists from her
I could never support you would never
support Trinity killing yeah I could
never even if it's for self for myself
as in like like for some person has said
I would like to die you know I would
like to I mean that's it's suicide isn't
it it's just yeah I'm a lot of people
want to die because of self pain like
internal pain but that can that could be
a method for that some people
some people can try things some people
don't get the right information and I
feel like that's where a lot of people
get lost I've worked in mental health
for a long time and that's all I heard I
want to die I want to die I want to die
but actually when you give them certain
methods and you help them process the
information and and their thoughts
um they actually change their mind so I
think it's you know someone that wants
to kill themselves not like they want to
actually kill themselves they either
want to change who they are or they want
to the pain or whatever they're going
through to stop
um yeah yeah so I'm curious
um so for the people that are pro-choice
if you guys saw new information would
would you ever change your mind on that
issue
like raise your hand if you would what
sort of information sorry I don't know
science like if we would then go against
abortion yeah like would you is this an
issue you'd ever change your mind on so
you would never change your mind you
would never change your mind
you I think it's always like good to be
open to new information I don't think I
would ever really dismiss an information
Source before I had
witnessed it I think it's always good as
a human being to actually reassess your
beliefs otherwise you're just like as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible